les documents obtenus par radio canada
en vertu de la loi d'accès à
l'information démontrent une inquiétude
grandissante au sein du ministère
selon nos sources les manoeuvres de jazz
and ont même bloqué des projets majeurs
visant à accroître la sécurité des
diplomates et du personnel à islamabad
kaboul et port au prince pour des
besoins urgents
la direction du ministère exigeait à la
construction de nouvelles installations
à ces trois endroits à très haut risque
mais rien n'a bougé
alors si vous me dites confrontons fait
des coupes aussi dans des décisions qui
finalement a fait que la sécurité ça ne
m'étonne pas